[أغنية]
ظهر أوبرا كروز تقريبًا طبق به
600 عام من التاريخ وهذا هو المكان
نحن نفهم أننا يجب أن نشكل
مدرس الاخوة من الطبق و
الكشف عن ذلك والد سكايب التسوق الجاسوس
في هذه
[أغنية]
ويدعو نونو مورا وحاضره
رئيس الأخوة تباس ل
أزياء الميناء
صاحب الصناعة إلى قائد
نصنع أفضل كرشة في هذه المدينة
من tripas à moda do porto هو طبق
تتكون طرابلس من معدة الحيوان
هو محارب اسم زاك دجاجة
gorda عرض نبيذ جيد للقمامة وواحد من
عصارة اللحوم caué الفاصوليا والجزر رغم ذلك
ساعتين عمل طبق كرشة جيد
جاء الناس من اللوحة إلى الميناء وجاءوا
من بعيد لأكل الكرشة في
أزياء الميناء
سبب وجود كوم فريري لدينا وليس كذلك
هي تلك الفترة المعقدة التي أذهب إليها
أوروبا في عام 2001 مرض جنون البقر
أوبرا اختفت تقريبا لماذا لا
إذا كنت تأكل خط اليد من الجسم ولكن من
tripas يحتاج إلى قدر كبير من العلاج و
التطهير والمناخ القاسي بالطبع
ميكروب أو بكتيريا غير موجودة
أكثر من 15 عاما لا يوجد مرض
في الأبقار في البرتغال ويفضل صنع أ
عمل رائع وساعد في تطوير و
تحفظ الكرشة بطراز بورتو
نرى حاليا كتيب 450 - نحن
كل عام نجعل الفتاة تتبرع
tripas ودخل 3 آلاف و 4 آلاف شخص
[أغنية]
مرة واحدة في السنة لدينا فصل كبير
هو الفصل الذي دخلت فيه نيزا
confreres جديدة
بالفعل في فيلم كاسترو عن التجارة
صاحب متجر يبلغ من العمر 29 عامًا واليوم من أجلك
توج في الأخوة تذوق الطعام
من الرحلات à moda do porto جدا
مهم للحفاظ على هذه المهن حية
وبفضل هذه الأخوة نحن
سنكون قادرين على الحفاظ على هذا الإرث
في السنوات القادمة سأقدم الأفضل
مساهمة
[أغنية]
القواعد الجديدة لـ
منى تمثل هذه الأخوة على أنها
هذه الميدالية ثقيلة بعض الشيء
لكن علينا أن نحمل القصة
من 30 ليس من السهل أحيانًا البحث عنه
لفترة في التاريخ نحن أهل
المنفذ وحتى ذلك الحين عندما تنكسر الأم و
تريد أن تشارك في قصتك
فن الطهو الاحتياطي
نفس هذه الراحة نسميها أنفسنا
tripeiros عندما يتصل شخص ما tripeiros
لقد فعلنا ذلك بسرور كبير
[أغنية]